без этого рост невозможен вам не
получится эффективно расти Если вы не
досмотрите это видео до конца все хотят
роста кто-то хочет роста своих доходов
кто-то хочет роста прибыли А кто-то
хочет роста качества своей жизни кто-то
хочет сделать карьеру А кто-то хочет
духовного роста мы все хотим расти
потому что это закон жизни вы либо
растёте и процветает либо деградирует и
умираете ничто не бывает постоянным
постоянным бывает только перемены Что
такое рост рост - это процесс
количественного и качественного
увеличения чего-либо как и у любого
процесса у роста в любую единицу времени
есть только одно и только одно
ограничение по-простому
тому что вы не растёте есть только одна
причина и ваша задача найти эту причину
и устранить Вы знаете я много занимался
поиском и выявлением таких ограничений у
бизнесменов инвесторов Да и простых
людей и вот что я заметил ваше
ограничение которое тормозит ваш рост
может быть на разных уровнях и в разных
сферах это могут быть и нехватка
ресурсов и нехватка знаний инструментов
это могут быть какие-то ваши
психологические комплексы зажимы это
может быть ваша система восприятия ваши
фильтры и предубеждения это могут быть
культурные традиции и верования короче
ваше ограничение может находиться и в
вашей психологии и в вашем менталитете и
в вашем характере и в вашем темпераменте
и в ваших ресурсах и во внешней среде и
в том как вы подходите к проблеме Это
тоже может быть вашим ограничением Ну и
ещё ещё ещё много
где каждый раз разбираясь с разными
случаями А я разобрал наверное более
вообще тысячи случаев Наверное это как
минимум Я пытался найти одно самое
основное ограничение любого человека
которое не даёт ему расти независимо от
сферы деятельности и вы знаете мне
удалось его найти Как вы думаете что это
что является главным ограничением
которое не даёт людям расти хоть в
бизнесе хоть в инвестициях хоть в жизни
так
вот внимание этим ограничением
является внимание и не просто внимание а
фокус вашего внимания на тех факторах
которые непосредственно
если не верите проверьте Возьмите ваш
ежедневник и отметьте те задачи которые
вы выполняли в течение дня и которые
непосредственно влияли на ваш рост на
рост вашей выручки на рост вашей прибыли
или на ваш личностный рост ну короче на
тот рост который вы хотите вы с
удивлением обнаружите что большую часть
времени вы не думали о росте и не
занимались делами ведущими к росту все
нахва срочные дела дела которые нам
нужно выполнить потому что кто-то
требует или просит сделать или там
кричит и так далее дела которые косвенно
влияют на наш рост Короче проблема в том
что мы хотим роста А по факту Мы не
фокусируется на нём вот дам вам
пошаговый алгоритм или план роста первое
Определите цель в чём вы хотите вырасти
в выручке в прибыли в личностном росте В
карьере и так далее
второе Определите метрики которые будут
показывать на то что вы растёте которые
будут показывать ваш Прогресс и которая
будет показывать на что нужно
воздействовать третье Опишите шаги или
задачи которые прямо влияют на рост то
есть что вы должны делать И что или
Какие действия приводят а к росту этих
метрик четвёртое фокусирует
либо делайте по остаточному принципу всё
точка Да вы можете сказать А как же
знания инструменты ресурсы и прочее
отвечу если вы будете фокусироваться на
том что прямо влияет на ваш рост вы
найдёте способы приобрести знания и
инструменты и ресурсы и прочее почему
так происходит потому что все всё на чём
вы держите фокус растёт Если вы будете
держать фокус на росте то вы найте
тысячи способов найти знания инструменты
ресурсы и прочее потому что знания
инструменты ресурсы и прочее приходят
под конкретную цель которую вы держите в
фокусе Если вы хотите узнать как и на
чём держать фокус Если вы хотите
получить ещё больше инструментов
стратегии трансформации своего бизнеса и
своей жизни переходите в моё
пространство которое я специально создал
куда я собрал свои знания инструменты и
лайфхаки ссылку я оставлю в описании
внизу И самое главное Вы помните Вы
достигаете не тех целей которые вы
ставите Вы достигаете только тех целей
на которых вы по факту держите фокус в
течение дня поэтому держите свой фокус
управляйте своим фокусом и Да прибудет с
вами успех